welcome back to 8701
um so in this lecture we are going to
start looking at an example
um process for which we can now with all
the tools we have in hand calculate
the matrix element transition amplitude
all right in more general terms we can
look at
all the examples and they're listed here
second order processes and one third or
the other process
we're going to discuss them in more
detail as we go along
and this is really just to give you you
know feedback for the different kinds of
processes we're going to look at
so you know the first one is elastic
scattering it's you know neural electron
scheduling that's the one
process we're going to look at here why
because this is the simplest case for
this process there's only one
leading order diagram which is exactly
the one
shown here for other processes where we
have
the same particle interacting we find
that we do have to
consider multiple diagrams for example
this one here
we have electron on electron scattering
and so we have to
calculate not just the this leading
diagram which looks exactly
like the one for the neurons scattering
but we also have to
include the cross team term where we
change the
outgoing electron lag and so on
um you know the processes are including
electron position scattering which is
called baba scattering
compton scattering which we discussed
the kinematics for already
but also inelastic processes like pair
ventilation or
pair production there's a very
interesting diagram here
which is the third order diagram which
is responsible for the anomalous
magnetic moment and we'll talk more
about that when we talk about higher
order corrections
so let's have a look at this electron
neuron scattering process
so only one diagram contributes at
second order
and so we have an electron and a muon
scattering
via the exchange of the photo and this
is after all the qe diagram
so now how do we calculate the matrix
element
we simply just follow the fileman rules
primarily as we discussed them before
and if you want to do this now you draw
your primary diagram
it's always very good and useful to draw
environment diagram first and label it
accordingly that's super useful if you
want to systematically evaluate
this process and then you start going
from
backwards from an outgoing lag back to
the
initial lag and you see this part here
you have
the u3 the third particle here
the vertex factor and the first particle
then you have a propagator here for your
proton it's given by minus
i g mu divided by q square
and then you analyze the second part
here
where you find the fourth particle
vertex vector and second particle
for each of those lines you have to make
sure that
energy and momentum is conserved into
the spread of delta functions
and then the last part you have to do
integrate
over your momentum all right
that's already there the next step in
your list of rules is
carry out the integration integrate over
q
that drops your delta function but you
are left with one delta function which
you also supposed to drop
um which then gives you your matrix
element
now here you're already done if you now
further want to evaluate this
diagram we actually have to be more
explicit about the sphenos involved
so what needs to be done now is have a
discussion on how to handle
the spin of the particles meaning being
explicit about
the streamers and in order to do that
we'll discuss how we treat spin how we
have to treat them either in an
experiment where the spin of the initial
particle is known
or an experiment where we have to
average over all possible spin states
so that's part of the next lecture
discussion